welcome to this video playing baby
Fisher recently played them and lost him
no particular recollection about this
game okay some kind of hair chalk style
hmm okay n95 is no threatened and Bishop
see success also 95 so that's not going
to happen yeah he's some trying to in
trying to cover these six in advance
preparing Bishop e3 yen's pollution it
weakens be three but ya can't have it
all and he's not going to play b5
anytime soon because of the sea farm so
snide efore move probably not
can like this move
and I can increase the pressure on d6
Queen a 2 a 3 or something then a 5
blundering my bishop that would be a
funny way to to play you still cannot go
Bishop c6 because of 95 I think this is
still interesting that idea couldn't we
can be 85 it's a typical idea that was
11 point of Bishop before that sometimes
a 5 is some prepared the ship c6 always
answered by 95 ed CD and the bishop is
pinned on the C file yeah so a 5 here or
not I can actually go I cannot create
three blunder stuff what if I'm what if
I pile up here that's possible good
defense but anyway the doubling here
cannot be so bad
yes now it's possible i can take c5 in
this position here but now it's not good
it's not good so let's grab maybe a five
now Breanna then you can take actually
Queen a 355 it's not cannot so sure
where that leads but it leads probably a
big ol know where they are not really I
don't really have a clear idea what to
do I cannot go b5 no can you go d5 but
it's not so not so clear what my ideas
my actual idea
I don't see a particularly convincing
IDM thinking about Queenie an idea for
bit of course i'm sitting there in the C
file can be tricky
you can take and going on okay taking us
not a problem it's a bit of a shaky
position somehow that's a mistake now
that's a mistake if I've is a real
mistake it gives me b5 now I get through
the night to be five first time then I'd
be five so Queen trade or not that's an
interesting question i think i'm trading
straining Queens debatable really
Wow going over to the g5 with the noid
so and it's reroute one minute left time
morning maybe I have to do it like this
and now play this takes takes g5
fatigues takes Bishop takes until they
take 1d6
ah difficult I'm trying the the third
option just preparing g5 mechanically
let's see check rookie five now the
point check check there was a what was
after a five a flag of orphans duty
disconnection after a five it was just a
total torture that was really a pretty
pretty big mistake it was really nothing
going on he defended or let's say defend
is wrong I don't think he really was
much worse or anything it was some he
played it played it totally fine and not
much was going on I had no idea I was
just shuffling basically and he and 94 I
mean he can probably just take that play
be five or so but that just is just
totally wrong in a five he has to he has
to earn yeah keep the position as is
it's a huge different let's say he does
this young then this would be a big
mistake as now he has that counter play
and I cannot block on b5 and here I can
this is this is excellent really right
here yeah this is an excellent position
then the thing is that
bleep Quincy three I wasn't sure I mean
after 23 it's it's super one-sided of
course but the screen has no squares so
I mean I'm not trapping it but you can
argue that let's say that King here f 43
slowly rolling forward could be strong
because the Queen has nowhere to go
there before Queen maybe that's stronger
it might be I was just tempted by this
end game ends weird that he went for
this deliberately but yeah he is just
the question is that holding or am i
crashing through I was shuffling around
a little bit also considering I don't
have that much time I couldn't find a
way forward then I regrouped for the
let's say the mechanical way of pushing
g5 and yeah I am mmm the computer gives
this this this this would have been very
awkward to face with no time Becky I
have g6 check in this which is pretty
strong actually but I would have yeah I
have to play it first check this seems
bad it really seems bad one now you
cannot avoid this story it's now falling
apart too many weaknesses yeah it was
interesting I if I've really was a
mistake and move that he has to avoid
and for other than that if he's playing
something different nothing much is
happening okay well thanks for watching